[Música]
a la mayoría de nosotros nos gusta ver a
los animales nativos libres
conviviendo entre ellos nos da la
sensación de que están bien plenos
lo que me dicen de esta escena
no nos gusta el grado nos dan ganas de
vueltas la carrera de cerrar los ojos
es lo que están sintiendo es justamente
lo que queremos cambiar la realidad de
millones de animales
tal vez algunas de las cosas que voy a
decirles no les gustan las de ser
fuertes como esta escenas y no quiero
seguir escuchando
pero es justo ante lo que nos molesta
que tenemos la oportunidad de
transformar los aguas tiene sucedió en
mí mientras estudiaba en españa un
encuentro cambió mi vida
no se mejora de invierno caminando por
la calle me topé con una manifestación
contra los abrigos de piel me acerqué
con curiosidad porque sólo era habitual
en el país y al conversar con algunas de
las mujeres que organizaban esta
protesta vi por primera vez imágenes de
los animales como nunca antes los había
visto
como no podía hacerlo
mi primera reacción fue también cerrar
los ojos pero este hecho despertó en mí
las ganas de saber más acerca de los
animales y aprendí que tienen un
complejo sistema cognitivo relaciones
sociales preferencias un mundo emocional
que con nosotros se alejan de lo que les
causa dolor y se profunda el placer
descubrí que paralela y realidad había
una vez muchísimo sufrimiento que el
agua nos dé tiempo de hacer algo y
comencé a leer más
hacerme preguntas y lee que el mundo
puede ser jugar muy injusto donde 20.000
niños mueren de hambre cada día las
cartas de agua potable matados y
millones de personas cada año entre 120
y 150 especies se extinguen cada día la
lista es muy larga
pero ningunas cifras y peras los 100.000
millones de animales marcados cada año
para consumo
cien mil millones cada año esto es 14
veces la población mundial
en todas las cosas que están mal en el
mundo yo decidí dedicar mi tiempo a los
derechos de los animales conocer entre
otras cosas la causa por un mayor número
de víctimas
y porque después descubrí que las
muertes de esos animales están
relacionadas con la falta de agua y
recursos para alimentar poblaciones pero
eso es otra historia
cuando fundé animanaturalis en 2003 con
francisco vásquez comenzamos haciendo
las protestas típicas contra las
corridas de todos los abrigos de piel es
cierto con el tiempo nos dimos cuenta
que no eran tan eficaces porque no
aceptaban a la gente a la realidad de
los animales
desarrollamos entonces la estrategia de
ponernos en el lugar de esos animales
apresados en las oscuras granjas
industriales y los diminutos espacios de
los laboratorios las segundas jaulas de
los hijos los zoológicos empezamos a
presentar la migrante que nos puede
resultar ver los cuerpos de artistas a
banderilla 2 pero como cuando se trata
de todos lo llamamos arte o cultura
nuestro objetivo en explicitar una
práctica concreta pero las formas de
ganar realidad tras generar empatía
hacia las crípticas y esto puede ser más
fácil vamos a dar los pasos se trata de
miembros de la misma especie pero cuando
son seres de plumas pezuñas o escamas es
tan sencilla
estamos con perros o gatos tampoco
comparta su delfín es pero si me dicen
de bajas todos ciertos o más a un pollo
no lo conozco mucho que transportaba
animales al matadero para descargar al
descargar
instalar mucho de lo que la publicidad
se había mostrado donde estaban paradas
sobre un pasto verde con sus terneros y
eran ordenadas normalmente por un
granjero y sueño
está montada sobre el cimiento
sobre sus propias veces a sumadas la
cabeza a través de barrotes metálicos
para alimentarse
qué estás pensando las llevan a nuestras
salas de rodaje artificial donde eran
hechos a gas unas máquinas pilas de
películas de ciencia ficción genial
asturias inflamadas con heridas en la
cabeza sangraba
los terneros estarán separados de sus
madres
unos cuales están reducidos con decenas
podían moverse estaban allí para que la
leche que por naturaleza electro
responde nostra viviéramos nosotros
pequeños en pocos días serían
convertidos en trozos de pan en nosotros
hermanos con normalidad
con este momento mi corazón contacto de
persona empatía con esos animales los
vientos se agotan el sexto es invitarlos
reconocer el potencial de su empatía y
desarrollando con las prácticas porque
en un corazón abierto la información
detrás más fácil
en mi experiencia como psicoterapeuta
puedo decirles que la empatía es tan
segura tema mental para compartir las
perspectivas las emociones del otro
preguntar para tratar de entender sin
culpar y creer las formas de
comunicación como activista es además un
tipo particular de atención que requiere
saber más acerca de ser muy bien amigo
tener una proyección
siguiente la empatía con un proceso
sería algo así
la situación del otro pacto versión
imagino que se siente estar en esa
situación de como en sus zapatos analizó
cómo esta situación afecta su bienestar
y busco lo que está en mis manos
parcelas de esta manera conviene emoción
iba son para conocer más acerca de ceses
y poder ayudarlo
y si queremos terminar no me puede poner
los zapatos de alguien que ni siquiera
son altos
la empatía de los animales no humanos es
de contactar con su realidad particular
y con fresas cómo puede leer se siente y
percibe el entorno y reconoce
de la misma vida que se desarrolla con
la práctica y al hacerlo concluimos
nuestra identidad porque nuestros
excesos con las relaciones que
establecemos y ser compasivos
indiferente ante el sufrimiento de los
animales dicen muchos de quienes somos
los científicos por ejemplo hablan en
términos de neuronas está con neuronas
de la empatía que nos permiten
silenciarlos o inventar situaciones
ajenas como si fueran propias
hasta ahora hemos hecho mucho énfasis en
que somos diferentes de los animales y
esto nos ha llevado cada vez que nos
entregas son las diferencias terminamos
discriminando raza nacionalidad género
preferencia sexual clase social especie
en cambio subyace el matiz en aquello
que somos similares y formas a veces
compartimos al menos la posibilidad de
tener experiencias de placer y de dolor
cuando descubrimos que las grandes
ministeriales mataderos circos
zoológicos laboratorios parques
acuáticos hay un individuo con una
historia una biografía una personalidad
única e irrepetible con nosotros mismos
entonces podemos reconocer que tenemos
una relación con ellos y queremos que al
parecer la coloques ahora que son los
alumnos de nuestra posición privilegiada
causando un gran sufrimiento a otras
especies
las fuerzas esta empatía con un proceso
revolucionario
y desarrollarla con la práctica porque
al hacerlo nos cambiamos a nosotros
mismos volviéndonos más suaves y
compasivos
al behrman esta iglesia que somos parte
de un todo que llamamos universo y
nuestra pareja es decir lo de la
compasión a lanzar productos seres vivos
y la belleza de las actuales
salgamos de nuestro pequeño mundo
particular para intentar adentrarnos a
otro ya otro ya otro con distinto que
nos parezca para descubrir que dos
mundos se conectan en uno más complejo
donde decisiones que creíamos
insignificantes como que comer que
vestir y como divertirme tienen el poder
de quitar o salvar vidas
pidiendo que hagamos algo inusual hace
100 años era una locura de conocer
derechos para las mujeres y fue normal
legal también entender expresar seres
humanos
los animales están en exactamente esta
situación
no sé cuál vaya a ser su decisión a raíz
de escucharles pero espero que considere
abrir su corazón desarrollar el
potencial de su empatía y extenderlo a
otros seres humanos y de ahí al resto de
las especies
porque nuestras manos está que la
relación con los animales sea una más
equitativa y solidaria para que quedamos
por la facultad de la empatía y el
espíritu de la compasión construyamos un
mundo más justo para todos
[Aplausos]
[Música]